- I'm really
grateful to be here,
and the reason I'm so grateful
is actually, you're
really helping me out.
I made a promise to the people
whose photograph ... photographs
who you'll see tonight.
I promised them
that their stories
would be heard,
and you're helping me
to fulfill that promise.
And so, for that,
I'm deeply grateful.
The last time that I
was here in the US,
talking about Where
Love is Illegal,
was soon after the
shootings in Orlando.
And, that event
was, you know ...
shocking, of course,
as it was to everyone
here, I'm sure.
But, it wasn't until
a couple of days later
that it really hit me.
I received a post
on my Facebook page
from a friend of mine.
He sent me this clip of
CNN's Anderson Cooper
reading out the names
of the deceased.
Maybe some of you saw that.
He read their names,
and they showed a photo
of each of those
who were killed,
and they had a little
story about them,
and what they meant to
their families and friends.
It was really,
really deeply moving.
And suddenly, those ...
The numbers became people,
and suddenly I felt
a connection to them,
and the victims were made real.
The mission of this project,
Where Love is Illegal,
is about making connections.
It's about amplifying
lesbian, gay, transgender,
queer, intersex,
voices that have
been silenced by bigotry.
And by hearing their stories,
we get to make real
their survival.
By understanding what
they have survived,
we maybe get some insight
and some understanding
of the true ugliness and impact
of homophobia and transphobia.
So tonight, I'm
going to talk to you
a little bit about
Where Love is Illegal,
the campaign,
I'll talk to you a
bit about the making
of the photographs,
because I know there
are some people
in this audience that
are interested in that.
But what's just as, if
not more important, to me
is that you meet some
of the individuals
who are brave enough to
be involved in this work.
This is Buje.
Now, Buje is covering his face
because he is afraid.
In fact, Buje isn't
really his name.
He asked that we
hide his identity
because who he is means that
he can be put to death.
I met Buje and
four other young men
shortly they had been
released from prison.
They had languished
there for 40 days.
They were tortured in jail,
and they were lashed
with a whip in court.
Fortunately, their
case was dismissed,
but the community
in which they lived
were not satisfied
with the verdict.
They waited outside
the courtroom,
armed with rocks
intending to stone
Buje and the other
young men to death.
Buje went back
into the courtroom.
His place of torture,
now a sanctuary until
the crowd dispersed.
But, his suffering
didn't end there.
They went back to
their families, who,
in turn, ostracized them.
Buje fell ill, and a
relative came to him and said,
"God should take your life
because you've caused
such shame to the family."
You know, their physical
scars would heal,
but that rejection from
their own flesh and blood
cut deepest.
So, what was the crime
that Buje committed?
What could possibly have
him tortured by the State,
nearly lynched by his community,
and abandoned by his family?
He's gay.
And, you know, one
would think that
we would've moved past
this barbaric notion,
that one should be killed
for who they are attracted to.
That to be LGBT is unnatural,
immoral, or unholy.
And while, there are now,
thankfully 780 million people
living in countries
where same-sex
relationships are legal,
there are 2.8 billion people
living in countries
where consensual
same-sex acts are a crime.
So, prior to starting this work,
Where Love is Illegal,
like many people,
I was a appalled
by homophobia and transphobia,
but like the Orlando shooting,
it wasn't until these
abstract concepts,
the abstract concepts of
homophobia and transphobia,
it wasn't until they
became real that,
through meeting these people,
that I had any
real understanding.
Of course, hearing their stories
cannot be compared in any way
to living their experience.
But in a small way,
when I heard what
they've been through,
I felt it.
So, trying to get people to feel
is what I've been trying to do
with my work for
the last 15 years
since I left my home
country of New Zealand.
I've been trying
to do that through
photography as a storyteller,
and as a human
rights campaigner.
I've done many
different kinds of work,
like sexual violence,
work about street
children and famine,
and conflict,
and dictatorship,
and displacement,
and environmental degradation,
and illegal mining,
and drugs,
and prisons,
and disease,
and large body of work,
which I've been
doing since 2011,
on mental health in African
countries in crisis,
which I called 'Condemned.'
Now, prior to starting this work
during all that other work
that I showed you before,
seeing this work here ...
You know, I was
starting to question
my role as a documentarian.
I felt that I had
made the beginnings
of strong, important, and work
that could have purpose.
In fact, it was one of the great
motivators for me when I
started out as a photographer,
I had this belief, like
many young photographers
who go into photojournalism,
that my work could be important
and that my work could
make a difference.
And I thought that maybe,
naïvely perhaps that my work,
by being published would make
people sit up and take action.
And sometimes, my work did that.
But, mostly it did not,
and that made me
deeply frustrated.
It was really important for me
that my work felt like
it was meaningful.
So, when I started this work
on mental health in
African countries in crisis,
I started it with a mindset that
my work could no
longer be made solely
to raise awareness,
that it couldn't just be
to illustrate an article alone.
I was determined that it
would make a difference,
and I started this work on
mental health in South Sudan.
I went there to cover a
referendum for independence,
and came away with a
story about a country,
which was in a time of hope,
had massive challenges
to deal with,
not least of all,
the psychological impact
of 20 years of conflict,
and almost completely
destroyed infrastructure,
and a country where
there are next
to no medical professionals,
and no facilities where people
with mental health problems.
And I will move through this ...
And this environment,
the prison had become a place
to warehouse people with
mental health problems.
And I move through this
nightmare of a place,
understanding that I was seeing
a really devastating
human rights issue.
That was really a crime against
society's most vulnerable
and voiceless people.
And I moved through
here thinking,
"If the world could
see what I was seeing,
they wouldn't allow this."
I was thinking, "I could
stop this with my camera."
I came across one
young man by himself
at the end of a cell,
naked and shackled,
with this thick colonial-style
chain around his ankle,
to the filthy floor.
And as soon as I saw him,
"I thought this is the picture,
this is the one that will
get people's attention."
Now, most of the
people in the prison,
as I moved around, were
able to let me know,
one way or another,
if it was okay to take
their photograph or not.
But, he couldn't.
He neither looked,
nor spoke to me.
In my mind, I was thinking,
"Okay, I'm here to document
a grave human rights offense,
and that's the most
important thing."
But I paused.
Here was a vulnerable young man,
whose dignity had been
taken away from him,
his liberty had been
and I was concerned,
was I abusing
his human rights further?
If this was me,
if this was my brother,
or if this was my son,
would I be okay with this image
appearing on the front
page of a newspaper?
So, all of these things
went through my mind
as I was crouching down
over this filthy floor
with a camera raised to my eye.
And the conclusion
that I came to,
because obviously
I took the picture,
is that the only
way that this image
was going to be okay,
is if it was made to
really make a difference
in the lives of this man
and the lives of
people like him.
Not raise awareness,
not illustrate an article,
but really make a difference.
So that day, in
fact that moment,
was transformational for me.
I moved from being a ...
My intention changed
from a photographer
hoping to change,
to make change happen,
to a photographer
making change happen.
I needed to say right now,
because I know there
are photographers here,
that, and lots of people
in the photo industry,
that I think there is
great value in photography
and storytelling,
just for the sake
of making pictures,
and for the sake
of telling stories,
and for recording history,
and for raising awareness.
Those are all really
valuable things,
but for me,
it wasn't enough.
I came to this conclusion,
and that is,
that with witnessing
comes responsibility,
and with privilege comes
the moral obligation
to people less fortunate
than ourselves.
I decided raising awareness,
raising awareness
was not enough,
and I decided that I
could no longer pretend
that making change happen
was someone else's job.
So, I tell you this
story about this journey,
because ...
to provide some
context and hopefully
some understanding
of my mindset when
I started to embark on this work
called, "Where Love is Illegal."
So, while I was
doing all this work,
mostly in Africa,
I was becoming aware of a rise
in homophobia and transphobia.
And this oppressive,
sometimes violent, reaction,
I think came from these
conservative elements
of many African societies,
which I believe was born
out of, in large part,
out of the rise in
visibility of equality rights
here in the US and
in Western Europe.
In this globalized world,
increased freedoms here
can be seen as a threat
to those who would
deny the freedoms
for people in their
own countries.
And then, we ...
You have to combine
that with the
fact that you would have
conservative Christian
elements in this country,
who were, perhaps, felt
like they were losing sway
and started to pivot towards
other parts of the world,
and starting ...
had these Evangelicals sadly
going to places like Uganda
and fanning the
flames of bigotry.
Encouraged by these
Evangelicals in Uganda,
bills like
the Kill the Gays Bill,
was brought into court
and passed into law.
But we shouldn't think that
this form of bigotry
was entirely imported,
there were local newspapers,
like Red Pepper,
who delighted in trawling
Facebook accounts
and taking people's photographs,
and putting them on the front
page to expose, in this case,
Uganda's 200 Top Homos.
Unsurprisingly, it's
happened in many countries
with this kind of reporting
and with these laws.
There's a sharp rise
in homophobic attacks.
The same homophobic
arguments that, you know,
many of us heard
in a less-tolerant
era in this country, were ...
Came out.
Things like the supposed
threats that gay men
have towards children.
It was particularly
disturbing to see
young kids marched
out in support
of homophobic laws as well.
But, later when aid was
withdrawn from the country,
and just a couple of days before
President Museveni of
Uganda was due to come
to this city to meet
President Obama,
the law was taken off the
books by a technicality.
So, while we have ... a
lot of people will say that
international pressure
doesn't work, clearly ...
And the Ugandan Government
would deny this too,
but clearly it did in this case.
So while Uganda got all the
international attention,
other African leaders also
saw some kind of benefit
in attacking a
community that was too
afraid to be able to
stand up for their rights.
So, the Gambian Government
was particularly
vile and vocal.
But, sadly, across
the continent,
there was wide
spread support for
these homophobic laws,
and it became a
very difficult topic
for me with my African friends.
Sadly, people that I respected
and who's time I
enjoyed being with,
almost entirely held these views
that to be LGBT was
somehow un-African.
That it was imported
by the west,
that it was a threat
to the family.
Most of ...
Everyone here will
probably think that
those sort of arguments are
repulsive and ridiculous,
but it's actually
not that big a step
to understand why they
might believe these things.
After all, there was
only one narrative,
and that narrative
was that LGBT people
were unnatural,
immoral, and unholy.
Of course, you know,
we have to also remember
that it hasn't been
that long that we've
had more accepting ...
We as countries, have
had more accepting views
of LGBT rights.
In fact, when I
was 12 years old,
my mother came to
me and said that,
if I turned out to be gay that
I would always be
welcome in the house,
but my "special
friend" never would be.
30 years later, my
mum's really proud
that I campaign for
equality rights.
So, there's hope there, right?
There's ... But you know,
you have to think,
what changed her mind?
She was exposed to
other narratives
that countered their
views, those views.
Views that said that
LGBT people were not
necessarily a
threat to her sons.
So, my mum gives me hope
societies and people can change.
But, these LGBT narratives
are very rarely heard
on the African continent,
and the community,
in large part,
is silenced and hidden.
But, this is not just
an African issue.
Clearly, half of the world makes
consensual same-sex
acts a crime.
And, you know, many
politicians see homophobia
as a way to garner support from
the conservative elements
in their societies.
This is the Malaysian
Prime Minister,
branding LGBT a ...
People.
LGBT people as the
enemies of Islam.
Of course, Syria is a
particularly dangerous place
to be LGBT right now.
One of the Syrian
men I met in Lebanon
told me that about ...
The Islamic State, when
they take over a new town,
or a new region,
one of the first things they do
is hunt down gay men
or transgender women
and capture means
almost certain death.
Russia introduced
homophobic laws.
They made LGBT
propaganda a crime,
which makes campaigning
for equality rights
quite dangerous.
And what followed?
Again, was a spike in
attacks on LGBT people.
One group became
popular on social media
for baiting young gay
men with hookup apps,
and filming them as they
beat and abused them.
So, in all these places,
what we have is
LGBT voices which
struggle to be heard.
Hate thrives where the
perpetrators of hate
control the narrative.
So I saw this single,
dangerous narrative
strengthen and become wider,
and I wondered,
as a storyteller,
"How could I contribute?"